this is just meat onion cheese yeah in
this perfect bun I was going to say
busted it's Burgers busting
[Music]
dude
now let's see it look at this it's a
good view right like a burger Illuminati
meeting first like I mean we're just
like like we just have to talk about
secret Burger things right now you know
with no one else around yeah no one can
see us we're at the corner beyond the
pier at the pier meet me on the pier why
are you excited about this season dude
it's all about the bbls
burger bucket list Burger bucket list
this season's all about going to our
favorite places right I'm gonna do some
on my own you're gonna do some on your
own but today I got a list today we're
doing it together baby that's right
people ask me all the time like what's
your favorite burger I can't do that I
know it's the craziest that's a crazy
question so if you do it by category
price this is a good way to do it price
is a great way to do it yeah I can't go
and compare a five dollar burger to a
big Ballin burger no it's impossible
impossible four places we're going to
today you ready no one can hear us right
white man in New Jersey New York metro
area Brandon and Carr oh one of my
favorites on Nostrand Avenue in Brooklyn
then we're gonna go to a newish place
called no one it's a great burger number
four we're gonna go to the faulty I'm
excited oh boy Jean George oh yeah Sean
is going to join us at the last spot she
loves baller Burger he's getting the
baller Burger
let's go let's do this let's go
[Music]
first stop the white Banner look at this
place wham wham amazing Hackensack not
new or the New York area New York
there's a trek out here traffic this is
I believe the most historically
significant hamburger restaurant in the
tri-state area there's no question about
it it smells so good in here
white beta was actually got its name
from White Castle
yeah now right you're thinking you know
what's the connection right yeah so at
one point in America if you did not use
the word white or Castle or some version
of that in the name of your hamburger
restaurant you aren't going to sell
hamburgers they didn't trust it period
how long has this been around we don't
really know I believe 1941-42
uh you've been to the original way yeah
Jersey City Jersey City shout out that
actually came from the 1939 World's Fair
okay that was the diner of the future
the idea of the diner of the future
which was that the griddle person was in
the middle it could serve everybody in a
circle all around them normally in this
category in the first category yes
subpar crap right yes this is actually a
fresh meat great bun fresh pickles
onions smashed into the Patty my kind of
burger right for 350. for 350. for a
double 357 how about that that's crazy
what do you think is the one ingredient
we're gonna see everywhere we go it has
to be onions onions are also important
in the history of the Hamburger because
onions are the first condiment okay
before there was ketchup mustard
anything it's fine I'm hungry let's eat
we got all we got a big day of eating
today these are doubles
it's very important these are doubles
okay
ah these buttons are steamed the buns
are steamy beautiful beautiful oh baby
so these are doubles which means they're
not double patties okay it's a double
meat Patty they're pressed together this
is an old school way to go okay
oh this is that type of burger you can
just you just have to sit in the corner
by yourself and just reflect on life
this is the original American slider
this is it yeah and I love it we're just
trying to figure whether what slider
comes from I really do believe that they
start on one side of the griddle and as
they flip it they flip them to the other
side they kind of slide across as they
go right it's low temperature it's not
actually super high it's not searing
beef well it's actually steaming the
original method comes just from the Need
for Speed just to make sure you get
burgers yeah and they're fast yeah what
blows my mind
people are still copying this burger I'm
so glad that this is our first stop
because this is going to tell the story
of our entire day yeah it's delicious
it's historic it checks off all the
boxes this is the slider this is the a
slider this is the slider
top number one white Mana Hackensack New
Jersey five dollar category it's
delicious
[Music]
stop number two Brandon and Carr we've
gone all the way from Jersey to Brooklyn
not a burger joint no not a Burger Joy
this is an old school Roast Beef House
we're here for the burger that's on the
menu
[Music]
I'm Eddie Sullivan Brennan and Claw
general manager owner here in Sheepshead
Bay Brooklyn so Brennan cause was built
1937 by uh Brennan and Carl themselves
they were two Carpenters when my father
took it over in 1969 1970 he added
another dining room if you look up into
the ceiling you're looking at the
original Rafters brick walls the siding
in the dining room I've been working
here since I'm 15 years old we have a
loyal staff our waiters come in we
provide them with a white butcher jacket
that we've been using since the 30s when
we cook all day long we're collecting
the juices from the meat and we dip off
sandwiches directly into that
we butcher our own meat here
we process our own chop meat for our
Burgers here we've got Julio Burger we
have these dear friends that own a
restaurant in Coney Island they're there
for over a hundred years so many many
Sunday nights they would come after they
work a long day most of the time they
bring their own Italian bread and one
side we get roast beef one side would
get cheeseburgers all of a sudden it got
joined together and the god Julio was
formed dipping in that trough or that
pot whatever you want to call it is an
eye catcher we love George we hope to
see him often the gargula burger yes it
is it's famous famous never had it
before yeah never I've always come for
the roast beef
never oh well okay good so I'm glad
you're here yeah I'm glad you're back I
just said yes I need to expand my
Horizon you ready to try this oh yeah
there we go look at that smell oh man oh
baby enjoy thanks man how you doing good
how are you how long you been here 35
years
a couple years worked in the kitchen for
a bunch of years and came back out here
started waiter do you have a pen on you
sure you know why right if you show up
to work without a pen uh-huh they send
you home
mandatory yeah thanks man thank you
thank you so much so while we were
talking this has been soaking just you
know what is that
you smell it smell it first
smell it that's the smell of
beef it's gorgeous it's sliced roast
beef okay top round hamburger patty
there's also two slices of American
cheese a griddled Spanish onions and the
whole thing has been dipped into beef
broth they have over there we got ours
double dipped you can also get a kfj
which we didn't do what is that which is
where they come when they bring more
broth in the table
it's called a knife and fork job
it's the burger show it's the burger
show we don't do those wait we don't do
that I gotta go away back up I gotta do
the plate pickup oh
oh man
um
wow where wet man is a classic this is I
think like a classic Plus
that's a deal absolute deal and that's
how you stay here when I come here when
I'm coming back from JFK what I usually
do is stop and get this burger and then
I get a cup of the of the broth and I
just drank it like a coffee on the way
home
dumb good
bye
[Music]
meet with the family and enjoy a nice
afternoon of roast beef and beer hey my
name is Joe this is uh this is Frank
Frank
Pete Mike Awesome Bensonhurst well from
the same Grammar School St Mary's in
Brooklyn I've been coming here since I'm
16. I love the roast beef with the
cheese and the onions
old men eating out
I've been coming here for like 50 years
man it's an institution look at look at
this place come to Brandon cars it's
great
a lot of ten dollar burgers are four
dollar burgers with a higher price
attack you're getting really great bread
the auju or the the gravy there's love
in that people take a look at the
kitchen
how are we going to get better than this
like I just don't know because Eddie
keeps tradition alive he is one of my
hamburger Heroes by far oh man that's
something that I look at like that you
have to admire that it keeps taking me
for like including in books and stuff
like thank you for just being here thank
you yeah
right now
thanks man
best way to finish a meal here
wow
this oh my God no oh [__] top listen
oh that's how'd you put that up dude are
you a chef or something yeah I haven't
messed those fingers I do not cheers
[Music]
that's hot
baby
you try to pick this [__] thing up
please
[Music]
step number three do you like kimchi I
love kimchi we're gonna find the
intersection between Korean comfort food
and American comfort food I'm all about
that
hi my name is Jay Lee I'm the chef and
owner of no one in East Village New York
city so the name no one is the name of
my hometown in Seoul South Korea so no
one is a korean-american pocha and pocha
is basically an eating and drinking
place for me it's to create food that
people are familiar with when they look
at it but when they taste it it's
something special like with the flavors
that they haven't tried I started a
pop-up right after I quit my comfortable
Hotel chef shop I had like six to eight
dishes and this burger took off and I
went from selling like Five Burgers a
night to selling hundreds it's called
legendary because this burger opened up
this restaurant no one it's inspired by
Big Mac my favorite burger growing up
it's on a sesame seeded bun that's
butter toasted it's a double smashed and
we also seasoned the patties with a
custom seasoning blend it's made out of
[Music]
stuff like that American cheese kimchi
Mayo that we make in-house bread and
butter pickles from pickle guys in Lower
East Side the real secret to this is a
homemade kimchi it's a kimchi recipe
that I that I was taught by my mom we
make 100 pounds of kimchi here every
single week that's where the Flavor of
Love is in that burger I take big pride
in serving one of the best burgers in
New York City I truly believe that I
think I'm the first of my category
Korean American Burger that twenty
dollar range
I'll challenge anybody we have a mural
on the wall of my grandfather portrayed
as Admiral diesel machine from the 15th
century and on the wall behind me
there's a slogan that he lived by which
translates to do your best no matter the
outcome I'm living the American dream
you know eight-year-old kid didn't speak
English moved to queens now has a Korean
American restaurant in East Village you
know I'm really grateful and I can't
take that for granted everyone's been
talking about Facebook for good reason
yeah I've been getting like tagged on it
people that worked with me have eaten
here and like just Rave about it so yeah
I'm ready a lot of like good burgers in
New York City are now edging up over the
15 Mark you have to yeah Ranch man just
knowing what's in this burger uh can't
wait let's do it yeah there it is thank
you chefs
oh man so here we have legendary
cheeseburger with American cheese kimchi
Mayo it opened this restaurant so I hope
you guys enjoy thank you thank you thank
you but look at how beautiful this thing
is the elements are obvious right
they've got a seated bun obvious right
you've got obviously smashed patties
obviously American cheese obvious right
the sauce is obvious but when you take
your first bite nothing is going to be
oh baby let's go here we go
oh yeah this is why this is so good
because it still holds to the standard
of a classic burger but there's
something pushing it just over the edge
you can be right oh my god listen I
might move back to New York for this
this is so good it keeps you on a future
Burger of yours oh my goodness this is
so comforting oh yeah a little spicy
oh I remember that spicy
spice is good that is a Korean American
Burger that is so [__] good it's
perfect
yeah we need a cut we need to cut and I
can just woof this down yeah pound for
pound you know at twenty dollars
that's hard to beat that is hard to beat
and then I know I'm like talking to a
lot of like restaurants out there but
step your game up they're like wow this
is the type of stuff that pushes you
just push the burner envelope I'm afraid
to do what you guys do because it has
way too much pressure I'd rather what I
do is I fall back on history I make
burgers that have been already been made
before and they're great the triggers
are trying to figure out how to make
those Burgers but make them exactly the
way they always have been made for 100
years right I'm afraid of this yeah that
is I don't know how I don't know how how
we figured this out this is the type of
stuff where you eat and you're like I
gotta go back to work we got one more
one more stop dude one more stop it's
not ready who you are I'm ready I don't
care if you don't like this burger
you're a fool
Sean Evans we're coming for you I licked
my play
here we are the top category this is it
this is it
you want to have a good time you want to
have a nice glass of wine but you also
sometimes just want to have a burger
luxury Burger purveyors of the highest
honor
I'm Craig Branan I work with Sean George
for 23 years a lot of fine dining
restaurants that try to do a burger and
don't succeed with creating something
epic and amazing is in my opinion often
just too much work going into it it's no
longer about the meat the crumb the
crust and the salt I grew up with White
Castle and White Manna for me I knew I
wanted to do something with a griddle
and something with onions when we were
sort of just playing with that idea it
occurred to me why not under fry a
frizzled onion and smash the burger into
frizzled onions and really get a crusty
crunchy onion experience embedded into
the burger underneath the cheese and
then it occurred to me one day driving
in onions and onions right why not serve
it with a dipping sauce like an onion
Jew like you would a French dip to dip
it into it was absolutely like oh my God
this is it we use these pull apart buns
from Balthazar start with completely
unformed unpacked loose ground meat we
use a custom blend of of aged short rib
brisket sirloin and Chuck we tasted I
don't know 30 different grinds so we
butter milk our onions toss them in
flour fry them put them on a griddle
with oil
smash the burger into the onion so
they're really embedded
gruyere cheese salamander complete melty
gooeyness and then we do the sauce the
Dijon the green chili and the and the
aioli mixed together pretty
extraordinary experience for under 30
bucks John George loves burgers and we
all love Burgers when he has it it's
just complete and utter silent for like
three minutes look who's here
hey guys thanks for being here man oh I
appreciate it you know some of the best
burgers I've ever had in my life have
been with you guys so I'm very excited
for the meal today yeah we rolled out
the red carpet yeah it's good it's that
time this is a high-end great burger
it's not just a burger that tastes great
it also has a burger with a view look at
that if you look at it it looks very
familiar doesn't it yeah it does it
looks like a clean vehicle right here
you know yeah well and it comes with its
own rice I don't know that's the sauce
it's a caramelized onion but the first
bite going in right Burger look at that
I'm going in right there look at that
you see that oh
man
um
so good I don't know
but many burgers you dip into right yeah
and you bite into it super juicy the
other thing that I like no vegetation
I was just thinking that you know like
we're not stacking high with the lettuce
or the Tomato like this is just straight
meat onion cheese yeah in this perfect
bun that is where it's at I mean I was
gonna say Bust it but
Burgers
it's next level busting
here's what I'll say though you know as
the burgers become elevated I think it's
time for like the Fry game to catch up a
little bit you know what I mean I feel
like that has not been like the the low
fries are the best fries when you go to
a
place for a special occasion yeah would
you consider a burger no no I don't
think I would you know uh it's the
biggest seller here I know I am and I am
like a high low guy but sometimes I
wonder does elevating it taste better
than the sort of like greasy spoons
Smash Burger and this one everyone talks
about so it's like I finally get to try
it and I'm like okay the best chefs in
the world are making the best burgers
and like for me as a burger lover
it just it's like the next level in the
game for me I'm just happy that the
Burger's being appreciated
right your legs work all your life's
work yeah but for nothing Georgia thank
you
but there are silly burgers out there in
New York City that cost twice as much
and they're just not as good as simple
as that this is this is a value
proposition you might have gold leaf
might have got yeah I'm not going to get
into details some caviar I'm not going
to get the details slice the fog around
perhaps possibly
wow what a great way to end this day man
thanks for having me oh hey wow good for
being here again
we've all been together we've all been
together have we no no it was great this
is a Jean George Restaurant right he's a
friend of mine I'm gonna go say hi to I
think he's in the kitchen
JG I'll be right back Burger bucket list
I hope you all enjoyed it we're out
I like the way this morning is going
chef with the smash
thank you I mean you you're the king of
Smash let's do this every day
[Music]
hello Internet it's your boy Alvin kylon
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button ring that
notification Bell if not for me
for the burgers
this show that show him the wine